what's up guys bang-bang new spots new
positions new haircuts lunch money time
on a Friday what while she's getting
rich throughout so I was just trying to
get a lunch money right
Here I am with the beautiful intelligent
and freshly cut plain Tamara Nova not by
him I didn't do it
nope you guys didn't get enough likes on
the tweet we went and got real haircuts
by the way by the way
huge huge complaint in society most
people I know go to a barber I usually
go to a barber you walk in you tell them
real easy hey for 25 bucks or 20 bucks
cut me up with your little clippers you
know get me a one on the side faded down
Doolittle to the top make me look good
you're a pro Paulina maybe go to a hair
salon person they want like 9 million
dollars and they want you to sit there
for an hour they ask you all these
stupid questions and then they do this
what is this looks the same just like
any other haircut oh my god you look so
much better so much time so much money
for the same thing I like the
commoditized barbershops can we talk
about billionaires attacking other
billionaires no let's do it okay so
Yulin mosque is a billionaire correct
correct
he is now saying he is criticizing Bezos
and calling for Amazon to get broken up
he tweeted this is insane Jeff Bezos
time to break up Amazon will not please
are wrong and this article literally has
a line in it that says musk does not
have the legal authority to break up
Amazon this is all over somebody that I
know online alex Bernsen i think the
same process last name has been tweeting
facts little data about coronavirus that
goes against the public narrative he
wrote a book like an e-book that
essentially is summarizing all of those
facts so this is based on academic
studies and actual data he then what to
sell it online on Amazon Amazon Road
he said we will not be selling this book
basically censoring him and so when Alex
then started to say hey Amazon censoring
me musk stepped in and said hey you
shouldn't be censoring this is a
monopoly break them up etc do you think
that Amazon is a monopoly that's the
first question yes why monopoly why
because they are killing competition
are they Shopify is doing just fine out
there Shopify stock has exploded they're
nowhere near monopoly isn't hey you have
to have it be fair in terms of everyone
has to have the same size business it
has to be they are preventing
competition and if Shopify that's one
company ok well how many companies do
you need a monopoly you know but a
monopoly would be one company dominates
ok there's two companies that's a
duopoly let's just say that if we were
all playing Monopoly with Jeff Bezos
he'd be winning right now that's true
but that doesn't mean that he should be
broken up who's more of an monopoly
Facebook Google or Amazon Amazon Amazon
probably Oh
but by the way Elon Musk this all came a
day or two days after he said he's gonna
take a break from Twitter and then it
came back firing just literally dropping
fire you did he took a break for like 24
hours and you came back to tell Jeff
Bezos that they should break up there's
a big break it's alright but don't don't
get your hair cut at a normal salon ok
wealth transfer what's going on come on
let's go let's go up the wealth transfer
okay so the corona so Jim Cramer is
saying that the kovat pandemic is go
ahead this is not a make up show you
told me about my lip gloss if I can't
promote my lip gloss you can't promote
your haircut I should be an actor Oh
guys come on okay so Jim Cramer is
saying that the stock market is rising
and basically he's saying that small
businesses are gonna suffer and big
businesses are gonna do even better now
after the Kubik pandemic and there's
gonna be a huge wealth transfer well
when he directly said was in quoting one
of the greatest wealth transfers in
history then he said the bigger the
business the more moves to major
averages and that matters because this
the first one
we're big businesses coming through
virtually unscathed if not going for the
gold
end quote yes but here he is missing a
key part of this he's just looking at
the stock market there's three key data
points that I think are important to
watch here one is the reason why there
is a wealth transfer is because the rich
get richer based on central bank actions
central banks are printing 3 plus
trillion dollars in the United States
globally they're printing even more
trillions that is inflating the stock
market and what is happening at the
exact same time is the bottom 50% of
Americans are disproportionately losing
their jobs so you get people who are of
lower socioeconomic status they're
losing their jobs their income they're
getting screwed all of the assets for
rich people they're inflating so you get
this huge divergence but on top of that
even worse if you look at the job loss
if you break it down by race I saw today
blacks Asians and other minorities
getting hit exponentially more by the
job loss and so what you're getting is
not only this wealth transfer based on
if you already rich you get richer or if
you're a poor you're getting poor but
also it's a long race lines as well some
of that is just structurally people
there's a bunch of studies that show
certain races are more likely to take on
certain jobs and those happen to be in
the hospitality industry they got hit
the hardest
but this wealth transfer is very very
real and it's happening in such a
compacted period of time like think
about it there's been a higher and
higher concentration of the stock market
in less people's hands over time I
forget the exact data fewer people but I
think I honestly think it's like the top
1% of the wealth in the United States
owes like 80% of stocks or some crazy
number like don't quote me on that exact
number but something like that so
they're benefiting so ok this is
interesting
wouldn't you say that because we now
also have Bitcoin there is also a wealth
transfer that will occur well I think
the whole argument for Bitcoin in terms
of equality is that right now for the
first time ever you have an asset that
can't be inflated because remember stock
I could technically issue more stock and
I could dilute you I can also do a stock
buyback
supposed to make it more valuable same
with currencies same with a lot of this
stuff but you have an asset now that you
can literally buy ten dollars worth but
real estate has similar properties of
inflation hedges but you need a lot of
money to buy real estate right so now
all of a sudden you have something where
somebody can buy $10 $100 $10,000
whatever it is and they can get and they
can benefit from it there's a a book
that somebody wrote it's called Bitcoin
and black America
this guy Isaiah wrote ahead on the
podcast he does a great job of
explaining like for the first time there
is education and an asset available to a
lot of the people in these communities
who previously don't have the financial
education whatever but the beauty of it
is it's non-discriminatory right anybody
of any socio-economic class can go ahead
and do this I don't know if you saw but
more Cuban recently was tweeting with
Preston Tish and they're going back and
forth and like Mark Cuban doesn't
believe in Bitcoin right so there's
still people who are like incredibly
wealthy and well-educated and have been
very successful in life like they don't
believe this he think it's witchcraft no
he's more of the belief of like the
endgame is not what bitcoin is like
bitcoiners believe that bitcoin will
become a global reserve currency
everything will be denominated in
Bitcoin like that's the the Fiat
experiment and all the printing that's
where we end up
mark is of the belief like why would
people spend Bitcoin if it's gonna
continue to appreciate more and more
over time right and so I look there's
good arguments in both cases at the end
of the day wealth transfers happening
should we stop it stop wealth transfer
yeah I just want I just want the wealth
and like the little people's hands I
don't really care about these massive
businesses I'd rather the small
businesses have the wealth that's why
Shopify denotes amplify one of their
mottos is no he's armed the rebels and
the whole idea is Shopify wants to help
all the small businesses go against like
the the Goliath right like let's arm the
David's the rebels yeah and so now give
the tools to the rebels
speaking of Goliath Apple has juicers
with a transition okay I see you got the
block I see you got the black uniform on
finally following let's go guys I think
minion mark I got here with the first
name okay that's trouble so Apple has
the years and millions of dollars on
automating its production lines with
technology yet it has always reverted to
using skilled human beings this begs the
question can people ever really be
replaced my dexterity can it really be
replaced of course they can why because
there's other companies who have already
done it look at Tesla's production lines
they're still humans involved in it yes
but a majority of it has been replaced
by robots
but Apple has smaller devices and you
need more dexterity than you do on a car
no they're doing surgery with robots
there's nothing more there's nothing
more nuanced and kind of sensitive than
literally doing brain surgery with a
robot because one one misstep and you
link will kill somebody surgery whatever
details don't matter to me story but at
the end of the day yes Apple could
definitely do this I actually think what
ends up happening though is where are
they feeling that they're failing as
much as what they're realizing is it
takes time to build the robotics right
and also they have supply chains that
they're rely on out of things like Apple
doesn't assemble any of this themselves
Yeah right they're relying on all these
other things which by the way I wrote
about today in the newsletter that I
write all about the concentration of
risk in China and also with very small
number of manufacturers the argument
previously was this is a pursuit of
efficiency so we trust people in China
to put this together because low cost
labor and they've done a good job in the
password and keep using it now as people
are being incentivized to move it back
on shore or to other geographies
machinery and automations could play a
huge part of it but it takes time to
build that stuff that sounds like an
interesting column maybe I should read
it are you mocking me no I just haven't
read your newsletter today she gets a
hair she gets a haircut now all of a
sudden she just takes over the show all
right well that's cool you like it it's
not a matter of like or dislike it's a
matter of Apple cannot freakin figure it
out
I think Apple's figured it out just fine
I don't think
okay so newspapers are facing an uphill
battle to survive this pandemic it says
more than 30 newspaper says have already
closed across the US since the pandemic
began so I actually believe that I it
not a big fan of national news or news
it stopped doing that
go ahead oh my god I think I think that
local news is much more impactful and
actually much more informative for the
people in that community the problem is
that there's not a lot of money for
local journalism which is really sad so
we all end up watching these like
figures on Fox's enn who are purely
entertainment not really real
journalists in my opinion but anyway so
interesting 30 newspapers have closed
their doors but I think what that letter
has done in terms of local journalism is
interesting because they've been able to
get these local journalists paying more
money and incentivize them to do amazing
local reporting yeah the virus exposed
shames in society
one of the biggest shams was the
business model of media companies the
media companies that have broken
business models are dying that's how
markets work you can't make enough
obviously they don't because the New
York Times the athletic etc have figured
out that there's a better business model
they're moving to subscription-based
business models where their readers are
providing sustainable recurring revenue
these small-time newspapers they were
built on advertising revenue on where
they call classified sections job boards
all those nonsense that that's just not
the world we live in today
and so either adapter you die they
didn't adapt they died did you hear
about this like what they want to do
with Google and Facebook No
okay so there's like a bill that's
proposed that would allow newsletters or
the newsletters news outlets to tap into
the advertising duopoly of Facebook and
Google what are they gonna do with them
to get advertising from them
yeah no again let the free market reign
and these people right have you ever
talked to somebody who runs the business
of a local newspaper yes are they the
smartest people you know do you think
that they can compete on the national
stage to run a sustainable business okay
so what ends up happening
you either and again they're good people
right they actually ran a great business
out that's at some point in time but you
either have to innovate or you die so
what is the answer to this how do they
save local journalism there they're not
going to get saved in their current form
they're gonna die and so actually the
smarter thing to do would be for them to
either sell their businesses now to
whoever the next idiot is to buy their
bags and you know to is to replicate
what the athletic is doing to do it for
local journalist but it's really sad so
I read this one really really well-done
investigative article about a community
where the local paper shut down the
local paper and shut down and the level
of corruption in terms of the political
regime in that small community just
erupted because there was nobody to keep
the politicians in check yeah by the way
I have a very nuanced view of the media
which is that most of the news that we
read is complete manipulation propaganda
and in many cases fake news but at the
same time I'm a huge believer that the
Free Press is one of the greatest kind
of pillars of our democracy and we're
seeing that with all the protests and
all this stuff where literally we have
journalists being arrested shot at
beaten up all this nonsense and so what
ends up happening is like how do you
solve this if I was somebody who wanted
to specifically solve the problem with
local journalism
I would do exactly what Ben Thompson
talks about Ben Thompson's whole thing
is let's say that you live in Murray
Kentucky I know a business that's there
and in Murray Kentucky there is probably
one person who every day should send out
an email and that email should say
here's everything that happened in
Murray Kentucky and if you're one of the
5,000 people that care about Murray
Kentucky then you should pay $10 a month
well if you do that and there's 5,000
people paying that's literally more than
half a million dollars for that one
person you could make journalism an
elitist thing not everybody has access
to the information so if you live in a
very low-income community people aren't
gonna spend ten dollars for your
newsletter when they could spend it
elsewhere it's just it doesn't work that
well then you have to deliver the news
through a different manner you could do
it let's say through audio what why does
it have to be written why don't you
literally record a podcast and post that
you have to adapt or you die and the
business model they currently are using
is it working and that's not my personal
opinion it's just the data is showing
that that model doesn't work so they
have to adapt there's other ways to do
it they aren't all foolproof right like
there's a lot of issues with those as
well but we'll see what happens what's
next
all right well private equity firms big
win for them
the Labor Department issued guidance
that would allow 401k plans to invest in
buyout firms so does that mean that I
can now invest in private equity firms
through my 401k well I don't know all of
the details of this and they're still
trying to figure it out exactly but that
is the hope or that is the goal of this
what is the two things that I'll say is
well one is the private market has
definitely shown to be some of the best
investment opportunities available in
regular investors have been kind of shut
out from the private market if you're
not an accredited investor you
previously have been unable to invest
there and then second of all is the pool
of capital you can use so take an
average American who you know has some
cash in their bank account they've got
some stocks that they own they have a
house that's probably their biggest
asset and they've got this 401k that
they usually are putting into mutual
funds or some sort of passive public
vehicles now there would be some level
of ability to put that into private
funds okay private funds a little bit
more risky you could argue that private
funds because they've outperformed
public funds in many cases are actually
less risky at the same time if you look
at it from the percentage of funds that
go to zero or don't return capital like
venture capital funds are definitely
more risky the venture capital firms are
yeah my whole thing at the end of the
day is I am a proponent of getting rid
of regulation let people give them all
of the options that are available and
let them make their own decisions you
have a lot of faith in humanity know it
no it's just I believe that the market
forces take over and if you're if you're
an idiot if you take your 401k and you
gamble with it and you lose the money
that's your problem you took the risk
but isn't there a sort of like I I want
people to be as a reporter I want people
to be informed and educated and on top
of things there's a lot of people who
just don't know but it's not your job to
look out for those people it's their job
to look out for them
educate yourself no one's coming to save
you and by the way that is what makes a
market the risk you take it you can get
reward but you can also lose all your
money hey are you a free market person
yet yes I've always been a free market
person I just have nuance well thank you
for you to understand I actually I
understand I think that you're a light
touch regulation person I'm a light
touch regulation person I I think that
there has to be a little bit to help
people prevent them from themselves
because people blow themselves up yeah
that's what taking risk off okay if you
could blow yourself up financially
easier I bet you more people would get
educated that's also true
like like let's actually you want to
drive an incentive to educate people
actually introduce some risk cuz right
now guess what in those mutual funds for
the most part you know who's actually
getting rich is the bankers the people
on Wall Street and everyone else are
trying to get their lunch money right
but the Wall Street bankers they're the
ones making all the money on the mutual
fund Oh time out bang bang oh we forgot
the sponsor oh [ __ ]
we're sponsored by black 5 get money get
paid whoo Brad for 401k plans we're
gonna talk about money get money get
paid block by is the sponsor they have
three products you can buy and sell
crypto you can deposit crypto and get a
US dollar loan or my favorite product as
an investor and a user is that you can
deposit crypto and earn up to eight
point six percent APY on your account
literally what you can do is you can
take dollars you can wire it into your
block five account they'll deposit it
into an interest-bearing account for you
and they will pay you eight point six
percent APY through that account it's an
interest-bearing account it is awesome I
highly highly suggest it if you don't
want to do dollars you can put something
like Bitcoin you can earn up to six
percent on your Bitcoin it's a
no-brainer go check it out click on the
link in the description will tell you
more at the end but now they can't say
that we forgot sponsors what happens
when you talk about your haircut and you
want to be a movie star
hey listen block five you guys need a
spokesman don't worry I'm locked and
loaded ready to go
alright silent retreat Oh Joe hit us
with the emoji go ahead why are you
ready for the silent retreat story this
mate where are you not speaking Oh
I was on a silent retreat gets a haircut
thinks he's cool okay so calm down okay
so on the morning of oh wait no no yes
on the morning of May 23rd this man
named Daniel came out a vase he rejoined
society after a two and a half month
long silent retreat and he tweeted what
I miss
oh sorry it's not another silent retreat
I don't believe it come on he went into
a silent retreat for the exact at the
exact moment that all this and then came
out at the exact moment it was all
ending I don't know I've never heard of
a 75 day silent retreat I've heard of a
30 day silent retreat I've heard of a
one-week oh one day a 90 day and never
heard of a 75 day he did it on his own
he went into a cabin and he's he's like
a monk of some sort if you go on a
silent retreat how do you know when
times up you just decide one day oh
you're no see you're like hey I'm gonna
go into like a hibernation like a bear
in the winter exactly and then one day
you're just like okay it would be pretty
crazy to come out now right I'm joking
by the way I do believe that he actually
did but it would be pretty crazy to come
back and be like wait a second hold on
40 million people lost their jobs there
was a pandemic there's riots in the
street wait what is going on he he said
after so after he came out he went to
like a gas station everything looked
normal then he went to a grocery store
and this is my favorite quote he goes I
would turn a corner in the grocery store
and someone would be there and they
would recoil
I haven't installed the Cova top rating
system at first I was like whoa what did
I do
yeah you just breathe dude you're just
breathing you got it
yeah that's pretty funny all right lunch
money time lunch money time lunch money
time lunch money time it's Friday you
know what that means we're giving away
$100 what should we make the
you should take the video go tweet it
use hashtag lunch money and what I want
to hear know what I want to hear is if
somebody made a movie about your life
who is the actor or actress that would
play you take the URL tweet it use hash
tag lunch money so random and if
somebody made a movie about your life
who is the actor or actress that would
play you I'll tell you guys on Monday
I'll tell you right now who about you
yeah Jason Statham that's not who I
would pick but yeah who would you pick
I'll tell you guys on Monday
now Bruce Wallace is old Justin
Timberlake no he's alright guys that's
it for lunch money we will talk to you
guys on Monday
I'm gonna take my silent retreat now new
haircuts bang bang hope you guys enjoyed
this episode of lunch money as much as
we did
don't forget lunch monies now sponsored
by black 5 so go check them out there's
a link in the description that you can
click on I'm an investor a user and a
huge fan what you're a bigger fan of
black fire than you are of me block wise
my second favorite thing in the world
behind polina they've got 3 products
they can give you a u.s. dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell crypto
currencies on their crypto exchange I
personally use the interest-bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find up to eight point six
percent interest on a deposit in an
interest-bearing account go do your own
research there's risk associated but
eight point six percent it's pretty
compelling so click on the link in the
description say thanks to the folks that
block by subscribe to our channel like
the video annoy plan in the comment and
we'll see you guys tomorrow and be kind
to your friends